hi I'm Antonio Brown and you're watching
Sims and let go what I've let go
Antonio if you do that again you're in
big-time trouble pal it is left go it is
Sims that's the way it should be said
this is Chris Sims he is a football
savant you know his dad seven years of
the NFL years you freaking idiot but
he's got a beautiful mind watches more
film than anybody right and this is Adam
Lefko the host my work wife and the
biggest mouth I know and he doesn't even
not that good of a friend he didn't know
I played eight years in the NFL thanks
friend doesn't matter we have a lot of
friends we're gonna introduce you to
today first young guy and then we go
from the east coast to the west coast
and we got Marcus Peters Helen I left go
hanging out some la ramps what are you
best at gambling in a shootin dice and
we sat down with the guy that took
Chris's dad's job Tony Romo I actually
think Sam darn old he's the best
quarterback to come out in a while
period all that is coming up on Sims and
left go but first Chris a little segment
for him though
and it's time for a whoa big headline we
had a big headline over the weekend
let's we were going nuts when the best
offensive players the NFL Khalil Mack
yes traded to the Bears and Chicago is
pumped and they should holy cow boom
Kaleo Mac turns the Bears into a playoff
team we had a bit like the 9 and 7 right
the British team right yeah I mean
they're scary prediction shot they're
scary let me just say this monsters of
Midway Khaleel macro kwan smith Leonard
Floyd a key mix the Bears defense will
be one of the best in football we love
Vic Finch we love that now he has so
many chess piece yes he does I look at
Coolio Mac like he used Alden Smith a
few years back to the 49ers outside
linebacker defensive end coming off the
edge they're gonna create havoc poor
Aaron Rodgers watch out for the Bears
front seven there's a sad side yeah the
Raiders in it I love Raiders we allowed
the radius trading Kaleo Mac was the
right move for the Raiders the Las Vegas
Raiders these Oakland people are getting
screwed I'm just gonna put it out there
what you thinks he's the best player on
the
it's not even close he was the defense
MVP two years ago I don't get it and
obviously was a money thing course but
the Raiders defense it slack it was only
bad it was below average and now I don't
know what it's going to be all right
last one
Davis Webb who was the star of the
offseason shocking moves so amazing in
this weight room he's got binders he has
playlists for Eli nice cowboy boots arm
is so strong was too strong he literally
said here's the thing though they have
passed on a quarterback in the draft and
Davis Webb's like I'm the heir apparent
to Eli right does this make you question
the say Kwan Draft with all these rookie
quarterbacks looking good no first of
all Davis web-like self appointed him
the heir apparent to Eli so pump the
brakes they're giant fans want Eli
that's all they cried for just a the
last year and a half I'll tell you what
I'm worried about with the Giants if he
like gets hurt their backup quarterbacks
are not very good this just didn't did
it like that's breaking new take it so
we do know that Webb is going to the
Jets but the future as you mentioned Sam
dard old we got Sam dartle rented a
little car just us thread of fun wanted
to show him New York City but we did
invite some friends
[Applause]
are you ready to give Sam a tour of the
city
wave to your admirers they're out there
win over York you're gonna have to hear
that day I'll shut them up if you have
to do what any tricky hazing yet and
even I kinda take everybody to dinner I
was saying yes yeah would you go up
thousand miles thousand my 11s across
yeah did it and I just want to admit
something yeah I'm a little upset that
you get to sit next to say when you were
briefed about this yeah like yeah you're
gonna sit yeah real Adelphia you're
right I don't know because with me and
Chris when me and Chris are talking
you're like not even really part of it
you know to really know New York there
are a certain group of people that are
royalty yeah and that is the fire
department I feel like that's something
that I want to be a part of maybe you
know after playing football so let's go
meet some of your biggest fans let's do
it
yeah yeah yeah he's here hey don't all
right ago good to meet you thanks to the
Jets meet the City
Sam's grandfather was a fireman that
surely was but we told them no going
down the fire pole today or anything
like yeah yeah we got to draw the line
there right yeah coach Bowles those
balls might get a little mad pray for me
area
boy this is my proud boy he's becoming a
New York man it is hot dude
he looks like a fart right what's up
fireman for the day
oh that's so much power is it so cool
I can only imagine if I was wearing the
jacket oh yeah you're a New Yorker now
it's official is that the number one
thing you hear like so Barban jet fans
like I hope you beat the past yeah Brady
in those guys right
fellow check-in those guys yeah yeah we
got to beat some other teams too now I'd
like to see some action Sims still
thinks he can pull up I don't know if he
thinks he can throw like the third pick
in the draft yeah I'm gonna go over 97
I'm gonna go out there and I'd like to
see you can hit my trash bin
Sam's y'all first sometimes Texas beats
USA
assume Simms has relied
[Applause]
[Applause]
42nd Street Time Square
Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
how many fights have you been in that's
the question I want to get I'm serious
he's just picking fights that I don't
know I am I can be conversational
fortune pose your team I don't know it's
gonna win it real soon let's start it up
here we go
[Music]
I want to be best friends with Sam
Darnell and I'm working on yeah yeah
stalker alert
call me Sam I miss you welcome to left
goes gift shop it's where Sims knows
football I know the internet and I try
to teach you the Internet through gifts
which I think are the best part of the
inner please teach me oh wise one
because I am clueless about the internet
I'm gonna show you a gif I'm gonna give
you a football take you tell me if I'm
right first gift is this one Thanos this
is what I believe JJ Watt will be
re-entering the NFL this season oh man I
still can't believe the Avengers lost
this battle but the heartbroken about
boilers boiler sorry deal with it and no
JJ Watt can't beat a nose he's like the
most charitable nice guy in the world
this guy's evil yeah getting ranked just
tearing up off I mean even a snap he is
scary and has a similar job but that's
about it next gift in the gift shop is
this bad boy I love this this is the
Ravens defense reacting to Nathan
Peterman starting in week one that's
that's awesome
funny how funny clay yeah they gotta be
thrilled
yeah and I mean seriously Nathan Peter
mean needs to be scared for his life
over/under three interceptions for
Nathan Peter I'm gonna go under but the
real question is over/under five sacks
on a Thor beater but you're gonna find
going over oh my gosh yes funny how this
is the love go gift shop this is what
defenses are gonna be like when they
face Jimmy G and Kyle Shanahan this
season oh I got feel that they're gonna
be like what what is it coming from his
office and Jimmy G's so handsome we
can't stop this this is unbelievable is
it gonna be awesome I think it is I mean
30 points a game 30 points a game Jimmy
G slam-dunk top five statistical
quarterbacks in the sport this year oh
that's amazing
yes it is I like that yes well we have a
next guest that was a top-five guy back
in his heyday again the guy that stole
your dad's thank you keep talking about
that Tony Romo ski again though you get
to sit next to the quarterback right
Merce and Arnold
now Tony Romo yeah sorry that's just
what happens this quarterback thing man
you stay over there host yeah thanks a
lot
the Sam dog that we spent time with them
okay I said one only coming out in the
draft one of the pro player comparisons
I kind of compared it to use your style
of play I said Tony Romo the way he
manipulates the pocket and can move
around and subtly move and make throws
so we're interested in just your thought
on him
yes pacifically and then of course some
of the other rookie QB that have jumped
out to you without making any glaring
statements yes whoo but I'm about to yes
I actually think Sam darn 'old is got a
chance to end up at some point right to
be the best quarterback in the National
Football League okay in the whole league
and the whole league I actually think
he's the best quarterback to come out in
a while
period kind of glaring yeah they've
noticed yeah I heard this some people
just have this rare ability for nuance
that I say our feel you know we talk
about you talk to feel the tackles and
creeping up in the end you're getting
ready to throw you just move and you
don't even know why you don't even know
why you might yeah you had that dude
yeah and that's why there's a
similarities further along than I am in
the sense that it took me years to get
the base to be strong and set where he's
coming in like that which is more Peyton
Manning ish that then I've seen of
anybody coming out and you know I know
it's a pretty bold statement stuff but
I'm willing based on what I've seen yeah
I feel very confident like I don't know
he's gonna have a good year this year
but I guarantee you within the next
three years yeah Sam Darnell is for real
one guy that definitely knows the
details is Belichick you're gonna have
to sit with him before the first game of
the year are you prepared for your
meeting with Belichick can you what is
that like when you have to sit there and
ask that man questions in a closed room
you know he walks in you know it's
Belichick you already know right
and sure enough he's got a suit on
that's four times too big you know it's
just it's like no he's stylism sits
there and doesn't smile or anything just
sits there and then that's like you want
to go first time I was like nope you're
you're going to run and Jim go ahead
it's like hey coach about six just like
yeah
and these like so what do you take you
guys you know look like you're gonna be
pretty good this year you know I gotta
get squat and everything is like that's
it it's really like that no words no
he's just gonna shrug you're making me
uncomfortable that's how it is most
uncomfortable like 10 seconds so then it
comes to my turn to talk and I'm like I
didn't care about his team then I just
start talking about the Giants and the
80s and you bring stuff up and he goes
down history land and that's when he
opens up yeah first he goes out it takes
your judge I mean yeah mr. mr. Armani my
family you told my guy my dad's joggers
guy do you have any money on you mr.
then what are you stealing my coaches
job I gotta pay for my kids how to eat -
not playing anymore barely making ends
am so are you ready for it to become
Romo and left go seriously no seriously
seriously no you need to get out of here
I'm Chad Johnson and I'm Terrell Owens
and you're watching The Sims and left go
straight like that they're also they're
awesome they're they're like us they are
but accomplished yes right I'm so
excited now with gambling I love to bet
on games I always steal his information
I try to make money on it and you did me
a favor
I wanted to bet against the players you
called Sean McVeigh and got me in a
ramse camp well getting you into camps
not easy so I had to pull some big-time
strings we are here with a quarterbacks
best friend
and his name is cool
[Music]
you would have throw to this guy a lot
when you were playing huh yeah how many
touchdowns in his dependable cans catch
last year he was a rookie sensation left
gone five last year alright so I am a
degenerate gambler I want to bet on how
many touchdowns you get this year so set
the line how many touchdowns do you
think you're going to catch this season
we're gonna move in upwards
Oh let's give it a lot I'm looking at
your team I'm seeing cooks and woods I'm
seeing Gurley I'm seeing all those tight
ends I'm gonna take the under but I'm
gonna make this bet if it does go under
I get a win if it goes over 9 or over I
will donate $1,000 to the Wimberly sand
their help for the youth in Cambodia is
that a fair deal to you all right so
here's the deal I'm a gambler okay
I do love coach you know I'm good at
gambling are you really well we're going
right now so I'm curious how many
interceptions do you think you're gonna
have this season I'm gonna go with set
the line that's a line that's the line
I'm gonna go with seven seven yeah I'm
gonna say that you go over seven
interceptions this year if I'm right
then I get a win I get a left go up if
I'm wrong I'm going to donate $1,000 to
the fam first charity pre-shave yes take
my bet
it's a bet this means we're gonna watch
you the entire season we're gonna keep a
Marcus Peters interception track you
feel me
Oh Garcia we're joined by I would say
arguably the greatest punter to ever
play in the NFL he's he's definitely the
best in the sport right now not only
does he punt though Sims he also throws
passes what is his average completion
per year per year he is one-and-a-half
completions per year about the same as
mine for my career at quarterback okay
yeah everybody equal how many completed
passes do you think you will have this
season I mean a lot got to be two it's
got to be just over average and so -
yeah I'm gonna take the under okay and
here what how does that make you feel
I'm ready to rise above it yeah rise
above excuse this guy two and a half no
you're - you said it he took it the hell
here's how this is gonna work if you get
under - I get a left go lock if you get
over - I will donate $1,000 to these
special olympics in your name I love
that is that a deal you go over - I'm
wearing your Jersey on the podcast I
want to bet on the premiere game in the
NFL each week you know exactly what I'm
talking about Thursday Night Football so
I went to my boss as a bleacher report
said guys I need $5,000 they said left
go you got it one catch I said what they
said you can't pick the team's fine
I know New York I know New York well I
went around the city and each week I'm
gonna find a random person to pick the
game against the spread if they're right
I'll split the winnings it's a little
segment we call somebody and left no
thanks Adam
you're the best alright I'm here with
ollie we are here we're selling
newspapers a you'll want to start bursts
awesome Ally's gonna be my better for
week one eagles falcons bleacher report
has given me money okay I'm gonna let
you make the pick if you get it right
I'm splitting my winnings with you
you get it wrong you will never see me
again for the rest of your life which
we've kind of a friendship now I I have
some information first this is an eagle
and this is a falcon mm-hmm so get in
got it okay next famous fans the Eagles
have Kevin Hartman the Falcons have a
ludicrous Suda okay
he said Luda he may have just been
swayed lastly two of the best players on
the team the Eagles have Fletcher Cox
the Falcons have Matt Ryan Ali who's
your pick look you gotta believe that
they even come out week one it's gonna I
like the Eagles he's taking the Eagles
Sims and left Oh first better the season
Ali's going the right birds the Eagles
if you're right I'm bringing cash back
to this game that I'm not buying
anything I'm just gonna give it to you
Matt if I'm right I see you did what do
you think Ali gonna be right Eagles
gonna win by three I think he can sell
some newspapers but man is he wrong your
Eagles are gonna lose sorry left go just
flat-out loose how'd I lose
yeah the best Island rise up Atlanta oh
go best all right so let's get some
Super Bowl pick since it is our first
show right my Super Bowl is a little
crazy
oh I'm fiscal I'm going with Aaron
Rodgers and the Packers to out dual
DeSean watching and the Texas I like it
I mean I like it too it's your two
favorite players and you put them on the
Super Bowl together but unfortunately
it's a team sport left go okay go I'm
going with the esses the Saints the
Steelers Super Bowl 53 Steelers world
champs how you like them apples what way
to really play it safe
yeah I just want to be right sorry
that's a good thing yeah thank good luck
thanks Chris before we go I want to give
you guys something for Sunday when
you're watching the games and all this
attentions been put on the helmet rule
we're starting a hashtag yes any time a
flag gets thrown that you're like are
you kidding me use the hashtag keep it
in your pants we're talking about flags
okay don't you sicko
yeah keep it in your pants we're talking
about flags thank you very much that was
Sims a left go before we go you've
noticed our set it's really beautiful we
have a lot of cool trinkets and gifts I
wanted to give you a gift because it's
our first show he doesn't know about
this it's to add to our studio I would
like you to open it I spent a lot of
money on something you did anything
work-wife okay check this out a lot of
money on there a lot of money like my
whole paycheck do you know how to open
gifts I see what this is though I just
Wow yes where did you buy this they
still sell these my dollars I was in a
set you got ripped off for $5.00 it was
a thrift store in Manhattan a Chris Sims
Jersey for $5 we're gonna put it right
behind your bronze spleen oh thank you
very much I really appreciate that I
cannot believe they're still being sold
in stores and I can't believe they gave
us a show Sims aleko appreciate you guys
so much that's it for Sims he's out
honey let's go in the words of Antonio
Brown let go talk to you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
same route just go long thank you
thinking whatever I do this in my sleep